welcome back to fox and friends welcome
back to tampa florida home of super bowl
55
we've been talking to you all weekend
about the state of florida the state of
being open the state of freedom and
experiencing it here
down in the sunshine state the man
responsible for that
is governor ron desantis in large part
keeping this stay open and i'm pleased
to be joined now by the governor himself
governor sanders good to have you
welcome to tampa bay and welcome to the
great state of florida
thank you now i want to point out to the
audience something when he says he's a
bucks fan he's not being a typical
politician running to the front
taking the popular position you're from
this area you grew up
a bucks fan yeah so when they had the
orange uniforms when they were
kind of the joke of the nfl played at
the old sombrero
the visiting team would usually have
more fans than we would have
so i was a supporter and you know we
were able to win a super bowl in 2003
which was great
but we've had some lean years and so to
be able to be here and hosting
the super bowl with the bucks in it with
tom brady at the helm
there's a lot of excitement here in the
tampa bay area absolutely i've made the
case by the way to bring back those
creamsicle uniforms
i think they're beautiful i'm going to
get your prediction in just a moment
but let's talk about being open i've
experienced it i've been out and about
in tampa this entire weekend
your state's been open this isn't the
first championship you've hosted not the
first big event you've hosted
um tell me about you opening this state
up and what it's meant for the economy
and whether or not
it's been a success well you look around
the country and they still are debating
whether schools should be open
we've had schools open the whole year
they talk about whether businesses
should be open
every business in florida has a right to
operate they talk about all these people
unemployed in florida
every single person has a right to earn
a living and our unemployment rate is
lower than the national average even
though we're so tourism dependent that
market hasn't recovered
at all our coveted though we have
less covet mortality per capita than the
national average
25 states are higher so the lockdowns
don't work
on their own but they cause catastrophic
damage to society
so what we've been able to do is other
states have tried to lock people down
we've tried to lift people up and i'll
tell you every time i go out
someone will come up to me and say my
kid wasn't doing well thank you for
getting him back in school or my
business would have failed
thank you for saving us or i would have
lost my job
those effects are going to make this
state so strong going forward
and i think had we tried a different
course that has not worked in other
places
i think it takes years and years to be
able to recover from the damage
maybe decades maybe decades in fact um
the data is clear you know it's come in
hospitalizations
transmissions mortality combined with
the economics of being open
but then that leads me to this and i
don't know if there's an easy answer to
this question but
outside of a few places the national
media has largely used you as a point of
criticism while celebrating governors
like andrew cuomo why do you think that
is in the face of all that evidence
well look they have a partisan agenda
and i think it was an election year they
did not want the president to carry
florida
i think the fact that the president
endorsed me when i ran for governor
you know means that they want to do that
so they had a narrative
and their narrative is whatever that
helps them advance their political
it doesn't matter about the facts they
don't care about the facts in fact they
will ignore facts
that are inconvenient for their
narrative and even concoct conspiracy
theories
as to why the facts aren't doing it so i
think they've done a horrible job
uh with what they've done but here's the
thing people aren't buying it because
people vote with their feet and they are
flooding into the state we have
investment coming in we have people
buying homes like never before
we have the fact just the fact that we
have schools open people are leaving in
every corner of the state just because
we have schools
we had sports we've had sports going on
the whole time i have parents who have
moved their kids to florida
because they didn't want to miss
football season which they would have in
some of these lockdown states and so
i think that there's the narratives that
some of the corporate elite media try to
sell
people don't buy it and this is a
perfect example because if people
bought their narratives you'd have
people leaving here to go to these
states that are supposedly doing so well
you've talked about voting with their
feet by the way are you going to try to
translate those into votes for
presidency
are you going to run for president in
2024 we've got a great uh governor's
election in 2022 which would be very
important for our state and quite
frankly i think
uh you know it gives us the ability to
keep the momentum going so that's what
we're focused on
focused on governorship but is that a
node running for president that's uh we
have 2022 to worry about
all right i want to ask you about this
you do have a bill you want to put
forward you know
everyone you know i don't know this is
limited to conservatives but free speech
loving individuals out there concerned
about not necessarily the government at
this time
but big corporations big tech companies
suppressing speech seemingly on one side
of the aisle and you have a bill you're
putting forward to try to rein that back
in would you tell me a little bit about
that
sure well one we're going to we want to
protect people's data privacy which
these big companies wrote that they're
not interfering in our elections by
de-platforming candidates and silencing
people they disagree with
but then we also the broader censorship
into platforming of society
i mean they have the author they have
the ability to wipe you off the map
online and it's not just someone that
may be making comments people's
businesses
are linked to being able to reach people
through these platforms
you have payment processing email text
messages we've seen they've wiped that
out for people that they haven't liked
that's very very ominous they're acting
as monopolies that are exerting more
power than the monopolies at the turn of
the 20th century like standard oil
and so they should not have this much
authority over american life
and i think our bill really empowers
individuals if they're not following
their own terms of service if they're
targeting you because of your viewpoint
well that's effectively a consumer fraud
and so we're allowing the ability for
individuals to be able to sue
and the attorney general to be able to
bring in students if you're d platform
during an election cycle and running for
office that's anybody anybody i mean
because what they do is they play games
with these terms of service
they don't um they don't implement it
fairly because just think about it
they will the platform a conservative
but then they'll let the ayatollah
khamenei
spout all this hate about israel and
jews so
so that type of inconsistency i think
gives rise to a potential cause of
action to protect
individual floridians rights no doubt
and i think
almost any conservative out there would
share your concern culturally
your concern over the spirit of free
speech but you're republican you have
conservative values
it's traditionally been a concern for
republicans that the government step
in in the way of a private industry when
it comes to free speech i heard you say
standard oil reference standard oil are
you talking about it potentially
breaking up the big companies the big
tech companies how do we balance this
government and free speech against a
private company so here's the thing
we talked about lockdowns and all this
okay and florida's success being open
big tech censored criticisms of
lockdowns early in the pandemic
and just imagine if we had a robust
debate on that some of those states that
are really dystopias now
maybe they would have chose differently
but if you put an article criticizing a
lot they would take it down
it was it was blatant censorship and i
think it's
contributed to a lot of lives being lost
and so this is a fundamental thing
so being able to structure the public
square
and what we're doing is we're not
intervening government to have less
speech
we're trying to structure it to have
more speech and i think that's a
fundamental difference as to how other
people have wanted to use the government
in the past in terms of breaking them up
obviously the state of florida can't do
that
but they are exerting more power just a
handful of companies
than other industries that have been
broken up in the past and so i think an
antitrust perspective
at the federal level absolutely needs to
be part of this conversation
well i think you're absolutely right we
know the cost the cost has actually come
in the toll of human lives when you're
suppressing the truth we know that when
it comes to covid
we know what this state has done we've
talked about the economy now let's bring
this home
do you want to endorse the creamsicle
uniforms or do you want do you want to
go ahead and give me your super bowl
prediction
you're gonna surprise me and pick the
chiefs no so here's the thing when we
hosted it in miami last year
i picked the chiefs publicly before i
said mahomes is the best player in the
league
they're gonna win and i think the point
spread i got was pretty close
and i told the governor parsons in
missouri we we welcome the chiefs again
but we welcome them with a little more
hesitancy and quite frankly overt
partisanship because we are rooting for
the bucks
but i'm also picking the bucks i think
that they're going to win i was
i remember the game in week 12 kansas
city outplayed us
that's fine but they're clicking now the
defense is playing a lot better
tom brady's really taking the reins in
terms of strategy so
i think they're going to do it i think
it'll be tom brady's 7th super bowl
and i think it'll be one of the great
achievements in nfl history if that's
out if he can get that done
can't wait to see if your
prognostication skills are on point
tonight uh before we go let's bring this
full circle we'll do news and sports put
together
i want to bring that conversation you
and i are having just over there we've
talked on this program
about states being shut down places like
california look high school kids in
california
they haven't had a football season some
of these kids tried to sign with
colleges in this last week it was
national signing day
they couldn't because they did not have
a senior season to showcase
any of their talents you were telling me
and in fact that has been another draw
to the state of florida
yeah so in fact our the guy that won mr
football in florida
it's a quarterback up in northwest
florida niceville high school
he had been more of a baseball player he
had played football but then he really
had a tremendous year
and now is able to get scholarship
offers had we had sports shut down
that would have never happened and so
that's just one example but you multiply
that across this country
thousands and thousands and thousands of
kids whose dreams were simply cut short
in florida we said
we're standing by your dreams we're
going to be there for you you have
every right to play if you don't want to
don't do it but we're not going to take
that away
we had successful youth sports season so
far we're going to keep it going
mental health future prospects
businesses and economy
it is great to see people living as
normal life as they can
thank you for joining us this morning
it's great to see you state opened up
absolutely thank you
all right